we're doing induction or not induction
it's up to us
and i want to demonstrate here
two cases of induction if i press the
first domino
all right wasn't perfect but you got the
point
and let's see what's going to happen
here if i press
oh and the last one fell
down
because i was trying to
demonstrate infinite induction with the
white dominoes and finite induction with
the black one
black ones and we will see how this ties
up with our problems so some of you have
seen induction before
while i'm explaining the basics you try
the following problem on your own
take any square
and into
how many smaller squares you can cut it
up so i want to know the number and of
smaller squares all of them so can you
cut it up into seven smaller squares
into
20 21 smaller squares and of course when
you're cutting it up it means no
overlaps and no funky business it's like
tiling on the wall everything goes
exactly in one spot
so what is induction induction is
a scheme or rather a vehicle
that you use to get from one point to
another in particular to prove your
mathematical statement
but induction doesn't work without the
driver and you will be the driver
you need to come up with creative ideas
to fit within
this
vehicle so let me give you a problem
that you may or may not have seen before
it's a very famous one find how many
subsets
does a set with
n elements
have so what am i talking about if you
have three
people how many groups can you extract
from them and so you can fiddle around
and maybe you will come up with the
answer eight that seems like a lot but
actually that's the case and we will
show it
and then you try with perhaps four
people
and
you know you count count count and you
come up with 16 and of course you start
seeing a pattern
and you're saying oh maybe the answer is
a certain power of 2
and the power of the exponent looks like
it's the number of people or the number
of elements and at this point you say
i'm going to conjecture that the answer
for this problem which i'm going to call
s sub m so number of subsets
if you have n people is precisely 2 to
the n where n is greater than or equal
to 1. and now that you have this
conjecture induction can kick in
one of the drawbacks of induction not to
disappoint you but i have to tell you
right away is that you need to know the
answer ahead of time induction by itself
is not going to tell it to you but once
you have it or some annoying classmate
of yours gives it to you pretending they
know too much you can use induction and
try to prove it so how do we prove this
particular warm-up problem so induction
starts with
turning on the engine your key ignition
so we're going to call it the bs base
step usually call it base case but bs
really caught you
so base case or base step
n equals to one so for one person
how many subsets do we have well we're
supposed to show two to the first two of
course i can have this person a by
themselves alone where is the other
subset brady do you see another subset
here
is it no people yes no people we forgot
about them great so that's true
we are done with the bs next i'm going
to do something called inductive
hypothesis ih so i'm going to make a
bold bald assumption
we shall assume
our statement is true
for some
n
greater than or equal to one and by that
i mean a natural number i'm not going to
tell you what this number is and that's
the key because i want a general frame
that works and then the creative part of
induction this is where you come in how
to show that the next statement is also
true what you saw with the dominoes we
place the nominals close to each other
so that when one domino tips the other
one is also going to tip
and fall over that is precisely what we
are doing we are assuming that the nth
domino falls and is going to trigger the
implants first to do the same thing okay
so in this problem we want to show
that uh if you have n plus one people
that means you have two to the n plus
one subsets
okay how does this work here are my n
plus one people i'm just drawing a few
points n plus one we're going to call
one of them brady and brady will either
be selected on a team to go to the moon
or not so we want to know how many such
teams we can send to the moon from those
people
so if brady
is not selected so brady is not happy
he's not going to go to the moon how
many teams do we have it means that we
are choosing
teams or subsets from the remaining and
people but we already assumed that our
statement is true in other words for n
people i have 2 to the n teams or
subsets uh-huh so if brady is not
participating i have 2dm teams now if
brady is participating how many teams
well what is such a team such a team
will contain brady and probably a bunch
of the others right but then such a team
means that i have to choose the
non-braidy part and add to that part
brady so braid is not relevant again
unfortunately i just have to choose a
team without brady two to the end of
those teams by our inductive hypothesis
and then add braid
okay so how many
do we have now
overall all i have to do
is add 2n plus 2n so that's 2 times 2 to
the n
2 to the n plus 1 teams
excellent so we just showed the
inductive step and here if you want to
be absolutely formal you want to receive
a receipt for your proof
you have to make a conclusion the
conclusion says therefore
all statements s and are true
for
all and greater than or equal to one
this seems like a lot to say but
actually that is the domino effect if
you believe that when the dominoes are
placed close to each other
then once you push the first one all of
them will fall
then you should agree with this or
alternatively let's think about
grindelwald evil magician okay so he
does all sorts of bad things on an
island the good magicians gather
together and they're gonna exile him
upon leaving the island grindelwald
casts an evil spell if he trains one day
it's gonna rain the next day it rains
today
will it rain forever brady on this
island what do you think
i think it will yeah yeah
and so it means that brady believes in
the method of mathematical induction
because in this example with the evil
spell
what is the bs the bs or base step is it
trains today what is the inductive
hypothesis and the inductive step well
that's the magic spell the inductive
hypothesis would be if it rains one day
and the inductive step will be therefore
it's going to rain the next day
and so we're going to conclude
that in this case grindelwald will win
on that island it will
every single day
so you might think about the domino
effect it's a little bit more optimistic
but either way will work now just a
little bit of a switch here
once you realize that the statement for
the number of teams
was correct
for n greater than or equal to one you
start asking yourself can i slightly
extend this doesn't action always have
to start with n equals to one how about
n equals to zero
would that work
so if you have no people how many teams
do you have
brady what do you think
two to the zero two to the zero which is
one and what's that team that's the
empty one
wow so we are extending actually our
formula to one more case and indeed
induction can start from wherever the
statements uh are true it could start
from 10 or you can even start it from
negative 5.
so now we are ready for the squares
remember into how many smaller squares
can we cut up a square without any
monkey business no overlaps no other
stuff so n is going to be the number of
squares and then we will say whether we
can do it or not okay so
if n is one obviously we can do it this
is our square there is nothing to talk
about but once we start going higher
things get trickier brady just think and
tell me one of those cases where you
think it's definitely possible to split
a square into smaller ones
four
four
yes and how do you propose i split this
into four smaller squares you cut that
in half vertically and horizontally
correct and we're gonna call this the
window technique we see a nice window
here so four is fine um anything else
um
i could use this you could you could
window all those squares oh i can window
in one of those and how many did they
get did they get eight
no no i've got seven
what happened so seven
is okay
but what happened every time you use the
window technique you are replacing one
square
with four
which means that you are adding only
three so once i have seven what else
would i have ten ten because we will
start adding threes here excellent and
obviously i can have them thirteen which
is out here but now what i still have
some gaps what i'm going to do with the
others this is not so easy anymore maybe
i'll help you unless you've already
discovered how to do it is there a way
to do it for six now
we have to be more inventive
okay
so suppose for a moment
i
split this into nine
squares right and everyone agrees into
nine
it's possible
oh
so that's possible
and then i'm going to use only some of
those for my six squares
in particular these four squares will be
now lumped into one large square well
how many do they get one two three four
five
six
ah so six works
and then from six on oh this is really
fun because i know how to do nine that
was our original cutting but now i have
another way to do nine right
i can use the window technique on my six
and split like that but at any rate we
now know that with the window technique
we can go and cover
another long sequence of of events here
we can do it 6 9 12.
um i wonder can we roll back to three
can you possibly do it with three
i can't quite see it so let me just let
this boil a little bit simmer on the
back burner
something else how about eight can we do
it with eight what we did with six
can be generalized for eight
so for eight you could in principle
do the following cut the side into four
equal parts just those two sides and
then go straight only along some of
those and finally cut up the remainder
so you're gonna get one large
two three four five six seven
eight total so seven small squares so
that's eight so we are done for eight
and that will trigger
11 with the window technique 14
and looks like we are fine from now on
so brady what do you conjecture based on
this table when is it possible from
where on is it possible well so far it
seems like it's possible from six
everywhere onwards correct that's where
the dominoes start
yeah and actually that's what i will
conjecture we will conjecture that this
is true or possible for n greater than
or equal to six why are you conjecturing
it i feel like you've proven it
well
i said and so on
every time when you start saying and so
on etc etc it means that you are
applying induction in disguise you're
just not communicating this to your
audience now
if you were a seasoned mathematician
that would be enough for them they know
how to
formally package
this kind of situation into induction
but if you're just starting with
induction
you haven't done it before
you may need a little bit of help here
and before i show you how to do this
formally
i want to answer the questions for the
remaining gap so what is going on with 2
3 and 5. the answer here is
no for all three of them so these are
kind of sporadic cases
where you cannot do it but the proof
that it is impossible for two three and
five is completely different from
induction
and in fact
showing it for three may not or may be
helpful for five but definitely that's
not going to be an inductive proof
so what shall we tackle first the
induction or those sporadic cases what
do you think brady i'd like to get rid
of those sporadic cases first okay yeah
i'm going to leave two for homework
because after you see the cases for
three and five you may quickly finish
off for two so let us see how it works
for three and five so suppose you can
split the square
into three smaller squares so we're
reasoning by contradiction i'm going to
use then three of those smaller squares
and push them onto my
bigger square so this is the one i want
to tile there are some ground rules here
they are corners in my big square well
how many little squares can i use in a
corner here can i use two
i don't think so because once i start
doing things like that it's going to
come out of my big square and that's
that's no good what we conclude from
here is that every corner of our square
will be covered by exactly one of our
smaller squares that's what everyone
should agree on
okay
but then we are in trouble because how
many corners do i have brady you've got
four and i have how many squares did we
say you're aiming for three for three so
what must happen one of those small
squares better cover two corners or else
we just can't do it let's say the green
square is going to cover the remaining
corner but what happens then
overlaps overlaps and i covered the
whole thing with it well
that's against the rules
now let us do it with five squares and
show that it is impossible for five we
have four corners so in this case
we have an excess of one little square
and as we reasoned before i cannot have
a single square like the green one cover
two corners because it will cover the
whole thing immediately so somehow the
fifth square has to be in between the
others
but now i have leftover sides like
right here between those two adjacent
squares so i need to cover those those
parts too
is it possible for one small square
to cover
two opposite pieces like that only if
it's the size of the whole square
exactly and i will let this for you to
play around and see it's just gonna
cover the whole thing so our fifth
square is going to dominate everything
and immediately show a contradiction
okay
we still don't lose hope we say okay we
cannot cover two opposite ones maybe i
can cover two adjacent pieces
what will happen in that case it means
that this brown fictitious square well
its sides still have to meet it's going
to go over our blue square and we don't
want that again we don't lose scope we
say fine i'm just going to restrict to
covering only
one piece on the side with my fifth
square but that means that all of the
remaining black pieces here have to be
covered by the original four squares so
i have to enlarge them in order to do
this okay so i will start enlarging the
purple and the green one they don't have
to meet in the middle they can meet a
little bit off like that that's fine i
can start enlarging the blue one yes and
i start seeing trouble now the red one
is supposed to meet at least the green
or the blue one
not both right but if it starts meeting
let's say the green one what what do we
see
we have covered everything there is no
place for a fifth one and we are
overlapping if i do for example try to
meet the blue one i'll again do the same
thing so you need to label the sides
probably x
1 -6 and so on and so forth go around
and really complete this argument but
visually it is obvious there is no place
for the fifth square anymore so
we cannot do it with five
we cannot do it with three and for
homework show that you can't do it with
two
now where is the induction here
mathematicians will tell you
that if you can
prove a statement without induction in
other words directly go ahead and do it
but you may not see that direct way and
that's why i'm going to demonstrate for
you something called strong induction we
need strong induction here in order to
technically wrap up this solution so how
does it work what is our base step it
turns out for strong induction you may
need several base steps
and
you can
easily convince yourself
that you will need three base steps for
six seven and eight and you will say n
equals to six seven and eight and you
will demonstrate for all these three
cases which we already did now what is
the inductive hypothesis
now
this is going to be tough because i'm
going to seem to assume
more than what i did before but in fact
these are equivalent methods so i'm
going to assume
all statements
s sub n where n is the number of small
squares are true for
all
and
from
6 7
8 up to
somewhere let's call it k so i'm just
not going to tell you okay but note what
i have just
done
i have assumed a whole bunch of
statements including my three base cases
if k is eight we are done i'm not doing
anything extra but if k is more i'm
actually making an assumption
so what do we want to prove
inductive step
is the creative one
we want to show
that s sub n plus 1
is true so what does it mean that we can
go one for the case higher now why is
this happening so i have gone up to n
just imagine the real line
we know that 6 7 and 8 are true and and
maybe some more
let's say up to here this k and now we
want to go
one more
higher right
so let's say n plus one as i said my
variable's a little bit funky but that's
okay so why is this case true as we saw
messing around the initial messing
around with the problem in order to do
12
you wanted to go back with three steps
and kind of undo one window technique
and that's precisely what you're going
to do here you will go back three steps
do you still land
on a statement that is assumed to be
true or did you accidentally fly outside
and land it on five which we know
already is not true the answer is no you
are still within the cases that you
assumed were true because you have this
barrier
of three
base cases that don't allow you to fly
over them when you subtract 3.
so you again land on a statement that is
true so you have some square that you
have somehow partitioned artistically
intercept squares and all you have to do
is go back by adding
one window technique to it and three
more and that way you will show that the
next statement is true and then you will
do this magic conclusion by the method
of mathematical induction
all of those statements are true this is
indeed using the method of mathematical
induction they're direct proofs
i can
give you a hint
first do this problem
for let's say a very large
even number
what's such a large given number like 2
000 can you directly divide it into 2
000.
you can do something like six and eight
what we did before so i will split the
sides into
how many sub squares do you think brady
a nice number
any number any no it has to work oh okay
see for eight we cut it down into four
for two thousand maybe we should cut it
into one thousand yeah so you're gonna
cut the side into one thousand squares
and then you will draw these lines
and continue doing your small sub
squares and one large how many do we
have
you may think we have one thousand plus
one thousand plus one but you are wrong
because we are just over counting this
corner so you have to subtract that and
bingo you have your two thousand aha i
think this example is general enough for
you to try even numbers right away
and then how would you do an odd number
if you add 3
to 2 000
you get an odd number so you just have
to hit one of those little squares with
the window technique and you will get
odd numbers okay so you can wrap this up
into a direct proof that will
nevertheless use two cases even numbers
and not numbers and you still cannot get
five there is no way you can get five
because if you go three backwards you're
gonna land on two and that's the first
and only even number for which this is
impossible
let's try to throw pies at each other
i'm sure you have seen those all black
and white movies where
everyone's having fights and pieing each
other not 3.14 pie actual pie
actual eating pie and the funny thing is
we're going to call it the odd pie fight
but it's not that the pie's odd but the
number of people involved
is odd so you have all the number of
people
and and they're standing somewhere so
that no two pairs have the same distance
so if i take any two different pairs of
people a b c d
i will see that a b is not equal to c d
and this also applies to the same person
for example
a d here has to be different from
everything else pairwise all distances
are different you have odd number of
people and let's make it interesting at
least three because for one person you
know you're not gonna buy anyone and
what do they do every person looks at
the closest to the other person and pies
them
for instance there are five people here
and it looks to me
that c is closest to b c is gonna pie b
what's gonna happen to e e looks like
he's going to
pie a
a probably is gonna pie b
b looks like he's gonna pie c
and d
d is very far i don't think anyone is
spying d
but d has to throw to someone i don't
know maybe e all right if you were in
that fight what would you like brady to
happen to you if i was in the fight i
would want to not get pied
correct
so do we have a survivor always in this
picture we can see that
this is definitely
a survivor but does this always happen
unpowered
unpaid so
that's the beauty of the problem
under these restrictions odd number of
people pairwise different distances
there is always a survival so let's
write this
conclusion there is always a survivor
i'm not claiming uniqueness or any other
funky things there is always a survivor
i've not seen that symbol before oh
brady we're learning every day yeah and
there exists a survivor and you look at
this and you say how can this have
anything to do with induction of course
it has something to do with induction
most likely because there is an n these
are infinitely many statements this is
like the dominoes but which statements
are we really concerned here
we want s3 to work for three people we
want s5 to work as 7 etc etc
s sub 2 k plus 1 all of the odd
statements
an induction will help us
show
the implication or if you remember
the
evil spell
we're going to keep on implying like
that all right so let's see how this
works all right what's the base step for
three people what kind of triangle can
this be it definitely cannot be
equilateral can it be isosceles
uh no no no no
that's right so it has to be something
called scalene right we will
label vertices here you know in those
old movies laurel and what was the name
harry hardy hardy hardy and laurel so
let us use l and h for them i have l h
like that and brady's gonna complete the
picture well i've just joined the most
famous duo in comedy history
yup
so in this love hate triangle what's
going to happen since it is a scaling
triangle i have
three different sides and without loss
of generality as mathematicians like to
say i'm going to say that a is what do
you say less than c less than b
something like that okay so a is the
smallest exactly so what's going to
happen with the l and h they're going to
pie each other yeah laurel and hardy are
pieing each other and brandy is watching
from far away
what is brandy brady you got hardy wrong
you're allowed to get brady right
absolutely but
that bee person
what is he gonna do
oh he he has to buy someone and it looks
like c is less than b
so hardy
gets pied twice
and we have a winner brady survives
great we've done s3 now by induction we
know how to proceed inductive hypothesis
we shall assume
that and this is not going to be strong
induction like for the squares it's
going to be a regular induction but sort
of skipping because we don't care about
the even cases
so assume that s 2 n minus 1 is true
so this s 2 n minus 1 is the previous
statement here for sum n
what should this end be and cannot be 1
because it's going to be s1
so how about greater than or equal to 2
because if n is true you're going to get
your s3 and we want to show inductive
step
that s2n plus 1 is true now i'm going to
use finitely many points a small number
so you can see how it works for instance
let's say
we are trying to show the seventh
statement but exactly the same idea is
going to work for any and so how many
points do we have one two three four
five six
and let's be on the safe side
seven okay so we've got seven people we
want to immediately eliminate some and
we go for the smallest pairwise distance
in other words which two people are
closest to each other looks like those
two and of course we're going to call
them l h laurel and hardy so they're
going to pie each other because they're
indeed closest to each other now what's
going to happen with the remaining five
people we are going to cool off our
discussion and ask them to play another
game just temporarily a game only
amongst themselves
only those five people
play the game but that's the previous
statement and we have assumed that the
previous statement is true so what's
going to happen for those five people
there has to be a survivor just for
those five people with this new game
someone survives this new game so who's
gonna survive brady survives this new
game what would you like brady to happen
in the old game with you you definitely
want to survive the original game with
seven people yeah if you survive this
one with five you'd like to survive the
original and they claim that you will
so whoever survives the smaller game
i claim that person is gonna survive the
original bigger game okay so now those
people who played the five person game
turn around and start playing the seven
person game
will any pie be thrown to break so what
what do you think
well
what happened before was that any one of
those five people playing the new game
they never threw to brady
so they had a closer target to throw
so in the new game brady is not the
closest person to them
because they already have someone closer
so from them nothing is going to go to
brady but what could happen
could a pie
be redirected from the new game to the
old game to outside to l or h the answer
is yes maybe this person who before pied
someone else here
is going to pie hard that's possible
so some of the pies in this new game
could be redirected to go outside to
laurel and hardy could laurel and hardy
pie someone in this game
no because they're the closest to each
other under any game
so no pies are going to fly no new pies
are going to fly inside our this this
blue game which means that brady is safe
he didn't get pied before he's not gonna
get pied now either and that concludes
the inductive step and now
we conclude the whole induction by the
method of mathematical induction all
statements are true in other words as
soon as you have odd number of people
positioned at different pairwise
distances there will be a survivor
brady should the survivor be unique
what do you mean
i mean for every game there should be
exactly one survival is that always
going to happen
i mean if you have two people very far
away
from kind of the other ones it looks
like they might both be survivors they
could both throw pies into like the
center of the solar system
but not nothing could go to them so i'm
not claiming that this is a unique
survivor is all i'm saying but i claim
that there is
a survivor and now for homework you can
try to create situations where there are
more than one survivor so there is
exactly one survival for fun to see
really what's happening but what's the
burning question that comes when you
solve this problem even number of people
even
why did we exclude the even pi fights
right let's see is s too true if you
have two people
it pairwise different distances but
there's only one distance between them
right laurel and hardy
there is no survivor they're just gonna
pie each other without question so we
already see that for two people we can't
have it well but you say this is this
really very simple maybe
i
could prove this
it's true for a big bunch number of
people even number right for example how
many 18 why am i saying 18 because here
is what we're going to do with those 18
people i'm going to construct for you a
counter example in other words i will
show you
that s18
is not true we can put them in a valid
configuration
where there is no survivor
so what do we do with 18 people brady we
marry them off in pairs disregarding
their preferences
just for the sake of mathematics they'll
do it
and now that we have nine pairs of
so-so happily married couples we send
them off to the nine planets in the
solar system i'm not gonna argue about
pluto don't even ask me okay
and we give of course
to the newlyweds a pie okay assuming
that they actually survive you know
conditions on these other planets what's
going to happen brady
they're going to pie each other in pairs
yeah the the spouses are going to pie
each other there will be no survivor why
is this happening because
the planets are so far away from each
other they outweigh
any individual distances
on a particular planet and that's why
there will be no survivor
so the problem makes absolutely no sense
for even number of people but there is
one little glitch that you should have
considered how about this business with
different distances
could we relax that could we allow same
distances
you would say well if i'm at the same
distance from laurel and hardy and brady
then whom do i pie
give them a choice
and
will there be still a survivor
could we be always sure that there will
be a survivor
the answer is no
because the simplest situation of odd
number of people that form an
equilateral triangle is going to be a
counter example they have a choice
so let's say laurel decides to pie hardy
and brady decides to pie laura
is brady safe
no because hardy could choose to vibrate
and so in this situation
you don't have a survivor so if you give
this freedom of choice to people with
possibly equal pairwise distances they
may not be a survivor so you cannot
relax the conditions of the problem the
perfect problem is exactly what we
solved odd number of people
at pairwise
different distances and just to be clear
you can have an even number of people
and have a survivor but yes but you've
shown that there's always a chance you
could always do it absolutely you can
put all of the other
uh how many people
20 19 people inside this room and send
brady to the moon right
who's gonna touch brady brady is
untouchable and he will survive that
even game too yeah so it is possible
we're not finished with induction just
yet in fact in the next video zvezda is
going to go back to 1988 and the
legendary question six from the math
olympiad which she managed to solve
using
you guessed it
induction
there are links on the screen and in the
video description
really poorly the night beforehand i
basically didn't sleep i was so tired i
knew that if i don't solve the problems
very quickly i'm just not going to
survive the test and they give you four
and a half hours for three problems
every day so this is day two